bonjour et bienvenue dans ce troisième
épisode de saw cas alors je sais pas si
vous avez déjà entendu parler d'elon
musk
bon il ya de vengeance étant donné qu'il
est assez visible en ce moment notamment
parce qu'il est le créateur de paypal
il a également créé et dirigé ce p 6 et
il est le directeur et fondateur de
tesla
l'entreprise qui crée les voitures
électriques on va s'intéresser à lui
aujourd'hui non pas pour ses réussites
industrielles ou technologiques
mais bien pour une citation qui l'a
annoncé lors d'une conférence qu'il a
menée l'année dernière
et puis bon si la démonstration n'a pas
convaincu vraiment tout le monde sur le
coup et que la théorie de la simulation
ne vient pas lui directement
ça a quand même relancé l'intérêt de
cette théorie et de ce concept notamment
de par le biais des réseaux sociaux dans
l'essence du maine est dans la
philosophie le concept de simulation est
très important et vraiment très
récurrent est peut-être un auteur parmi
tous les autres amener encore plus loin
ce concept de la simulation et il s'agit
de jean baudrillard
[Musique]
donc jean baudrillard est né le 27
juillet 1920 et il est mort le 6 mars
2007 il vient d'une famille assez
modeste il est fils unique et son père
les gendarmes
il va cependant réussir à devenir
boursière et va préparer son concours
pour rentrer à normale supérieure et
pendant sa préparation de concours
il va commencer à rejeter absolument
toutes les universités et tout formatage
qui selon de lui est imposée par
l'éducation à son époque et donc il va
devenir ouvrier agricole dans un premier
temps puis maçon dans la ville de tarbes
puis après quelques années il va quand
même décidé de revenir à paris et il va
obtenir son capes en allemand de là il
va commencer à produire plusieurs textes
notamment du théâtre comme brecht ou
vice et il va également traduit de
l'allemand vers le français plusieurs
textes de karl marx
puis il va décidé de s'orienter vers la
philosophie politique de là il va écrire
une thèse qui va s'intéresser à la
sociologie de la vie quotidienne et à la
discipline associée à la sociologie
urbaine bon logiquement on peut trouver
ces thèses en ligne moi personnellement
j'ai absolument pas une pour acheter les
livres il va publier sa première oeuvre
le système des objets en 1968 dans cette
oeuvre
il revient sur les différentes
représentations que l'on monte retient
face aux objets du quotidien et de
laquelle façon finalement toutes ses
représentations affecte nos usages et
affecte l'objet en lui-même
à la suite de cette première publication
il va écrire à ce type de consommation
qui en fait on entretient la même
logique que cette première publication
mais cette fois-ci étendu à l'ensemble
de société et à l'ensemble de nos
rapports sociaux
il sera ensuite en hauteur très
productif puisque dès 1968 à 2007
il sortira plus de 50 ouvrages et en
fait tous ces ouvrages vont plus ou
moins comme base justement la question
du rapport au réel est également cette
question de la représentation et de son
impact sur notre rapport au réel
en cela il est dans la droite lignée des
auteurs peau structuraliste alors
justement j'aimerais faire une vidéo qui
revient sur tous ces courants la sphère
l'existentialisme sur le post modernisme
sur le structuralisme
alors dites-moi éventuellement dans les
commentaires si ça vous dit
vidéo chronologique
sur comment ces différents courants
pensée se succèdent et quels sont les
plus grands auteurs de chaque de chaque
courant et qu'est-ce qu'il faut le dire
par rapport aux autres voilà tu peux
essayer de faire ce genre de vidéos la
ccisam si ça peut vous compte
bref trêve de digression on va
s'intéresser au coeur du problème à
savoir la théorie de la simulation et
donc peu de briare soir en 1981 son
livre fondateur pour cette théorie de la
simulation il s'agit de simulacre et
stimulation alors la théorie de la
simulation c'est quoi bon
c'est une théorie qui est un peu raide
en soi donc on va essayer d'y aller car
moment il sort deux pasteurs une
définition qu'on peut donner de la
simulation
c'est un système efficace des signes qui
est une réduction symbolique du réel où
on réel pour cette petite définition on
va essayer de faire un petit schéma donc
le réel est composé d'une multitude de
signes qui nous permette de
l'interpréter par exemple une maison il
nous faut regarder c'est différent si
que soit cette porte ses fenêtres sa
façade son toit et tout son volume pour
l'interpréter comme tel en fait pouvoir
dire cette maison fait partie de
montréal
toutefois dans une simulation qu'elles
soient numériques et analogiques
il n'est pas possible de simuler chaque
molécule de ciment où chaque centimètre
carré de charpente
c'est tout simplement trop fastidieux et
techniquement trop complexe donc pour
pouvoir la simuler il faut s'accorder
sur des symboles qui vont représenter la
maison dans un jeu vidéo en deux
dimensions
on va pouvoir simplement destinée à la
passade et dire que c'est une maison ici
c'est la ressemblance avec le réel qui
va nous faire comprendre que l'on a
voulu placer une maison dans la
simulation
cependant sur les cartes routières ou
par exemple une carte ign
il n'est pas possible de désigner la
façade de chaque maison donc dire que
chaque carré où chaque rectangle grise
et représente une maison les conventions
qui va être établi par celui qui a créé
la carte
appuyé par les gens qui ont fait des
cartes avant lui est soulignée par la
présence du rectangle billy en question
dans la légende de chaque carte
en cela on dit que la simulation est la
condition sine qua none à la
représentation
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas représenter
le réel sans simuler donc du coup les
livres les bandes dessinées et les jeux
vidéo en général sont justement une
réduction symbolique du réel une
simulation qui nous permettent de
représenter le réel donc baudrillard va
partir de ce principe de la simulation
et va la profondeur dans un premier
temps baudière va dire que la simulation
ne renvoie pas au réel mais à l'absence
de réel donc pour expliquer ça en fait
il va opposer simulation et
dissimulation dans le cas de la
dissimulation
on va feindre de ne pas avoir ce que
l'on a alors que dans la simulation on
va feindre d'avoir ce que l'on à part
donc dans un cas on va renvoyer à la
présence et dans l'autre on va renvoyer
à l'absence la simulation est temps
selon mme boudrias l'absence but réel
il va d'ailleurs prendre l'exemple du
patient pour expliquer ce concept
lorsqu on feint d'être malade on tente
simplement de faire croire que l'on est
malade alors que lorsque l'on simule la
maladie on peut même déclencher des
symptômes qui sont propres à cette
maladie dans un cas le principe du réel
et garder intactes et dans l'autre il
est remis en question
parce que la barrière entre du coup
entre le réel et l'irréel devient floue
par exemple comment on peut dire que
c'est de la simulation ou c'est pas de
la simulation à partir du moment où un
patient va simuler tous les symptômes de
sa maladie
justement c'est à ce moment là que le
principe du réel et l'irréel et remis en
question et la frontière entre les deux
devient très flou en second lieu il dit
que nous vivons aujourd'hui dans un
hyper réel il dit que dans cette société
d'image et d'information
l'amoncellement de sens et de
projections du réel va dominer
l'information en continu les réseaux
sociaux les effets spéciaux et le cinéma
en général vont être autant de voile qui
vont se poser devant notre orientation
du réel ces images et ces discours étant
eux mêmes ex trail d'une réalité qui est
voilé par d'autres représentations issu
d'une multitude de médias et
l'information c'est à dire que les
médias et les images qu'on nous propose
sont eux mêmes réalisés
par des individus qui ont été influencés
par d'autres images d'autres discours et
d'autres individus et c'est là aussi
qu'il dit que le real a disparu c'est à
dire qu'il n'est plus caché que par des
voix et qui finalement ne dissimule plus
rien une prolifération des images et des
discours qui fait dire à baudrières que
d'ailleurs tous ces semblants du réel le
réel n'existe plus la simulation a happé
le réel si bien que nous ne voyons notre
réel que par simplement par le prisme de
la simulation
bon c'est un concept qui est un peu
raide et un peu hyper encaissé on peut
s'il est assez contre-intuitif vis à vis
de tout ce qu'on touche lorsqu'on
regarde de ce qu'on perçoit comme réel
et en plus on peut trouver assez de
commandeur d'exemple dans notre
quotidien qui nous permettent de dire de
contredire ce que voudrait en train de
proposer ce moment en fait c'est une
proposition qui reste intéressante dans
la mesure où nous amène à questionner
des notions qui nous paraissent acquises
comme la notion de réalité de vérité de
réelles de factuel et tous ces
éléments-là la simulation finalement
d'aller remettre en question c'est aussi
un outil qui permet de garder un esprit
critique à ses fins sur toutes les
images et tous les discours qui peuvent
s'offrir à nous et ça peut également
faire réfléchir sur la façon dont ces
images et ces discours vient influencer
notre représentation du réel
enfin toujours en simulacre simulation
beau lien va parler de la précession des
simulacres
donc là on s'accroche bien son site
parce que c'est encore assez raide donc
baudrillard dit que le simulacre n'est
jamais ce qui cache la vérité c'est la
vérité qui cache qu'il n'y en a pas
enfin il dit que le simulacre est
toujours vrai pour expliquer ça on va
prendre un exemple baudrillard prend
lui-même dans son livre on va prendre
l'exemple du watergate
le watergate pour les plus jeunes c'est
à dire moi aussi c'est une affaire
d'espionnage politique qui se passe
entre 1972 et 1974 aux états unis en
gros histoire se résume
au président nixon qui va envoyer des
cambrioleurs locaux du parti démocrate à
washington pour voler des infos et
effectue des mises sur écoute
mais bon des journalistes vont remonter
la piste et vous remettre en évidence
que c'est bien nixon qui est responsable
de ces différents actes qui sont
hautement idéaux et finalement nixon va
démissionner le 9 août 1974
cette affaire baudrillard la présente
comme une simulation alors non pas une
simulation des actes illégaux qui vont
être commis ou même une simulation de la
démission de nixon mais une simulation
de la morale politique ou de la
politique elle même
c'est une mise en image et une mise en
action du principe de moralité on
s'indigne et on va dénoncer on va
contraindre à la démission
de ce fait on va donner l'impression que
dans un système politique
six infractions il y a punition son
suivra c'est pour réintroduire le
simulacre du sens du sens moral que l'on
va créer cette réalité fiction bon a
enfin comme a expliqué j'ai bien
conscience que c'est une notion qui
était difficile à intégrer
d'autant que notre rapport au réel et
notre rapport au concept de simulation
peut différer selon le nouveau rapport
aux images aux discours et à notre
sensibilité face à ces à ces concepts là
donc on va essayer du coup de résumer
en trois étapes le cheminement beaudry a
donc un la simulation elle renvoie à
l'absence du réel et non à sa présence
de deux on vit dans un hyper réels
c'est-à-dire une expérience simulée du
réel et de 3 la simulation est vrai
c'est la vérité qui cache qu'il n'y a
pas de vérité donc cette théorie la
simulation bien qu'un peu obscur elle
est assez intéressante à analyser parce
qu'elle nous amène un petit peu à
remettre en question nos préconçues et à
réévaluer finalement la dichotomie qui
peut y avoir entre d'un côté le réel et
d'un côté la simulation mais alors
revenons elon musk et sa théorie de la
simulation c'est à dire le fait que
notre réalité telle qu'on la conçoit
aujourd'hui
finalement elle est stimulée par une
machine informatique et que finalement
tout ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui est
purement virtuelle alors qu'est ce que
vos prières pourra répondre à ce type de
conception
bon on va pas prétendre parler à sa
place mais on va s'inspirer d'une
réponse qu'il avait faite par rapport au
film matrix dans une interview qu'il
avait donnée au nouvel observateur en
2003 dans cette interview il est
question du rapport entre le film matrix
et le travail de baudrillard en fait le
parallèle est assez intéressant car la
simulation proposé par matrix est assez
semblable à la proposition faite par
elon musk
si dans les deux cas le but de la
simulation n'est pas le même
il est toutefois intéressant de noter
qu'ils âgé de deux propositions où nous
vivons dans une simulation qui est
générée par informatique et qui est
assez convaincante pour comme
l'interprète comme le real d'où tu
dépenses mon livre je vais te botter le
cul à toi et à morpheus et que derrière
cette simulation se cache un réel auquel
nous n'avons pas accès car nous sommes
limités à cette simulation informatique
interprété comme le real ce que dit
boudrias c'est qu'il ya une différence
fondamentale entre le concept de
simulation qu'il avance et matrix parce
que matrix propose une distinction
claire et nette
d'un côté il y à la matrice où les
agents font régner l'ordre et les
humains sont sous contrôle et de l'autre
le réel et si on la cité des résistants
c'est clair c'est net et précis et ça ne
mène pas à la confusion
dans la version d'elon musk c'est un peu
la même chose d'un côté il y à nous dans
la simulation et de l'autre une
intelligence artificielle capable de
produire la dite simulation alors que
dans la simulation selon baudrillard
cette frontière entre le réel et la
simulation est autrement plus floue le
propre de notre univers c'est justement
qu'on ne peut pas utiliser les
catégories du réel pour en parler ou
pour la définir la vision de la
simulation par elon musk
elle est intéressante et a piqué notre
curiosité et elle est intéressante à la
fois sur le plan philosophique mais
également sur le plan justement
mathématiques ou physique simplement
c'est aussi intéressant de concevoir une
autre vision de la simulation la
simulation seconde selon baudrillard est
intéressante dans la mesure où elle
montre qu'il ya vraiment une très très
fine frontière entre la simulation notre
représentation du réel et éventuellement
le réel si elles existent pour finir
cette vidéo j'aimerais vous conseiller
de contenu alors le premier c'est une
vidéo qui a été effectué par pi bi essam
qui est une chaîne anglaise qui
justement revient sur l'aspect cette
fois ci très mathématique très physique
de la simulation selon les lots de
masques qui est très intéressante elle
m'a été conseillé par un ami et la
trouve vraiment passionnante
si vous aimez justement un petit peu
toutes ces notions là tout ce que
l'informatique pourra nous permettre de
faire par l'avenir et tout ce que les
technologies pourront éventuellement
être et pourront faire à notre
perception du réel et à notre quotidien
en général alors qu'on soit
éventuellement qui ont séché les cours
d'anglais il ya également la vidéo l'île
de cornwall même qui est un youtube
heures
très connu et qui est très cool et qui
fait une vidéo hyper intéressante aussi
sur la simulation selon alan masqué et
vous conseille également de visionner
dans un second temps je vous conseille
la conférence qui s'appelle la violence
et aux images qui une conférence qui a
été justement donné par baudrillard et
qui revient sur cette idée de simulation
par le prisme de l'image et qui est
assez passionnante qui est encore une
fois à ses rêves
au premier abord mais il fallait aller
vraiment plusieurs écoutes pouvoir bien
la comprendre et pouvoir bien assimilé
tout ce qu'il disait mais sa voix est
assez agréable la conférence se suivent
bien quand même
et donc du coup je peux que vous l'a
conseillée mais mais voilà surtout
paniquez pas si au début c'est un petit
peu incompréhensible au fur et à mesure
on s'habitue et des concepts qui
reviennent et qui permet de bien
comprendre ce concept de la simulation
voilà donc c'est fini pour cette
troisième vidéo j'espère qu'elle vous a
plu j'ai conscience qu'elle était un
petit peu plus raide que les autres un
peu plus dans ceux ci
j'ai eu du mal à expliquer certaines
choses et potentiellement j'ai mal
expliqué le surf un concept n'hésitez
pas à me dire si c'était trop compliqué
trop dans peut-être trop longs aussi et
donc du coup je ferai en sorte de
m'adapter pour les prochaines vidéos
dites moi aussi si vous souhaitez que je
réalise la vidéo dont j'ai parlé un peu
plus tôt dans la vidéo qui revient sur
les différents concepts des sciences du
mais des différentes écoles dans
peut-être dans leurs pronostics pas
histoire que ce soit plus clair et qu'on
puisse les avoirs des plus facilement
dans les prochaines vidéos
en attendant je vous souhaite une
superbe journée soir et nuit tout ce que
vous voulez et jeudi à la prochaine
salut
[Musique]